while you're in it
and you're going through this
and you're having you know you're saying
150 poles i've been there you know two
decades all this stuff
what do you know on the inside of the
involvement of biden's what they were
doing hunter and his father well
did i know that he was knows iran in
ukrainian business yes
did i know what he was doing no
did i care no why i mean because i was
working with the obama administration
the obama administration the obama
embassy in kiev
needed my help i mean the you know one
of obama's
first major
international victories was getting all
of the uh nuclear fission uh waste
product out of ukraine
uh there was a big conference on you
know collecting all of the the from the
various soviet countries that had
nuclear by-product uh there was that
were weapon-grade you know
nuclear product
obama in the west was trying to put it
all under control of the west
and
russia was totally against it
and
yanukovych in his first year as
president
sat down with the biden with the obama
administration and got the deal done
with the huge you know
objections being
expressed by putin and i think was
medvedev at the time um
in russia
and
and so
i was working with the embassy on a
regular basis whenever the embassy in in
kiev u.s embassy in kiev had a problem
with for u.s business companies or or
for something that was going on
politically that they disagreed with
what was happening they'd reach out to
me
and i would and i would work as an
ombudsman if you will with them and
every one of the ambassadors um
you know if
mundane things is getting jeff piatt's
dog into the country because he couldn't
get it into the country it's a big deal
to him it was
to uh to over working with them to make
sure the international observers got to
go to every district to watch election
results as they wanted to
um and so by the way this you're saying
this is under the obama administration
yeah who was secretary of state at that
time
okay yeah who who reset the russian u.s
relationship right the button that she
couldn't even press correctly
to reset the relationship i mean
you know so when you hear
rachel maddow and people thought i was
working with this russian oligarch in
2005 six and seven because that's when i
worked with him uh who was very cl who's
very close
to to uh
to putin
now
but wasn't then and he wasn't part of it
then
um
it's no different than when obama became
president and i was working obama set
the reset with russia not paul manafort
um and what he reset
was
the time the political relationship
between the two countries
my oligarch that i was working with it
was at a different time but now the
stink of putin today
and the image of of of putin today is
being held up as what i was dealing with
and for with deripaska back in 2000.
it's totally different
but there's no distinction between putin
and
u.s attitudes in russia
from 2004
you know with with bush to
2009 and 10 resetting it with obama and
clinton uh to
2013 when putin went to war against
ukraine and the west and even then obama
blinked and let putin get away with it
which is why you're saying with crimea
and what he tried to do with these quote
independent eastern uh
uh zones of uh of influence in ukraine
and donetsk and lehance
yeah so
it's just all blurred together
and there's no distinction between you
could have been for
medvedev when he was president
the u.s was looking at him as
potentially being the end of putin now
and and because they viewed medvedev as
a bureaucrat and somebody who didn't
come out of the kgb
uh and so his which is one term of
president
uh that putin actually put him in on
they were hoping he would become
a two-term president and putin would
fade into history and if that had
happened i think the world would be very
different today
but they didn't do anything to help
medvedev
and they and
at that time i was trying to promote
you know
western uh foreign policy
because i saw the difference between
medvedev and putin and how that could
impact the world but also more
importantly from my vision at that time
ukraine wasn't met with the the the
individual who uh obama got caught with
a hot mic isn't that the conversation so
what was that
so
what are your thoughts on what happened
there well i mean that's another part of
the hypocrisy of the attacks against me
i mean here uh you know
obama gets caught on the hot mic saying
to medvedev tell vlad i can be a lot
more flexible in dealing with him after
my election because this was done in the
secretary this was done i think in the
fall of 2012. um
and uh
and obama meant it he wanted to be more
flexible and broaden relationships
partially i think because he recognized
that putin was not going to let medvedev
have a second term and he was going to
have to deal
with uh you know he's saying to the
current president medvedev
tell the prime minister i'm going to be
more flexible what is that what kind of
signal does that send
well medvedev you're still the lackey
and you're still the power even though
medvedev you're the president yeah and
russians know how putin in particular
knows how to read these signals
um and and so guess what happens in
2013.
2013 you have the cu you have the
revolt in russia and ukraine and uh at
2014 crimea gets invaded because
obama putin doesn't fear obama they you
know and then he puts who does putin
fear
well right now he probably fears
zelinski he thinks so i mean he respects
him a lot more he'll never say that
but you know he's just
with him with a citizen militia has just
defeated the russians okay but that's
that's that's misleading because it's
not a citizen militia just by itself
they're backed and armed to the teeth by
the united states government
we've sent them 15 billion dollars in
federal and military aid we are now
switching from soviet-era weapons to
nato weapons were also providing
providing them intelligence so it's not
just a citizen well they are completely
backed in a proxy war by the united
states well no i mean you're you've
you've blended it all together
they
what they did the first month
where they blunted the the so the
russian invasion in kiev was done with
the remnants of the lethal aid that
trump gave them
obama wasn't given a lethal in the first
place again they're still backed by the
state whether it's trump of course or or
biden they're still backed by the united
states well
barely now now biden has gotten much
more active he's the the two the
secretary of state and the minister of
defense have just gone to
uh ukraine because he's got to
why though because because there's one
it's the right thing to do yes but but i
i wonder how this ends up because even
back in 2016 in the obama doctrine obama
was interviewed by
david goldberg of the atlantic and said
and said that the united states has no
interest in ukraine because russia can
always exert dominance over there that
there's no interest to us okay so
again it's it may be the right thing to
do but why is it the right thing for us
to do okay we're continually providing
aid or continually providing
intelligence and day after day we get
more and more involved in this proxy war
with the second strongest nuclear power
in the world okay you've said a bunch of
things that you need to break down here
because number one you said correctly
what obama's policy was which was it's
not our it's not our backyard
okay i happen to think 44 million people
who want to be part of the west
deserve to be
given the tools they need to become a
part of the west
i also happen to believe that putin
showed his teeth in 2014 when he invaded
crimea and we didn't do a thing we
barely registered objection no sanctions
of serious nature were put on there were
sanctions but they were not significant
and what happened as a result of that
putin then moved into eastern ukraine uh
in 2014.
that got stopped pretty much because of
ukrainians not because of the west uh in
in pressure that the europeans were
starting to feel now and it was an
election year coming up
uh in the united states
then so so now putin sees all of that
trump becomes president and obama
refuses to give any lethal aid
any lethal aid which
people here don't follow but the people
over there do right and they understood
the significance of that putin
understood the significance of it so did
the ukrainians and so how did the
ukrainians get their weapons in 2016
through
mercenaries through you know the arms
you know the underground arms operation
and and that's how they were able to get
some but not enough
then trump gets elected president what
does trump do for almost first things in
first year in office he gives lethal aid
now putin is seeing a change in the
leadership of the country
you know this pro-putin president new
president donald trump is given lethal
aid and it said don't mess with with
ukraine
putin pays attention to that
biden gets elected president
biden brings in the same foreign policy
team that was dealing with this area
under under obama new titles new chairs
but it's the same team
putin understands what that mean first
thing biden does is he makes united
states energy dependent again by
shutting down new production second
thing he does is he removes the
sanctions that trump put on on north
stream too
which were serious sanctions absolutely
and what what does that putin see there
okay i got the i got the obama foreign
policy team in place now i got
biden helping me you know and build my
my my energy
position in the world
uh and because the us is going to be
becoming a net exp importer
the the extra flow of
gas is coming from russia through third
parties which means he's making billions
of dollars more to fund his war machine
in moscow so he sees all of that and
then he says
you know to to the west don't bring
anybody into nato what were his
conditions for peace and not not having
him invade ukraine he wanted the
commitment that ukraine would be not be
part of nato well ukraine said they were
not prepared to be part of they were
never going to be a part of that so that
wasn't an issue but then he said and i
want all nato country borders with
military western military troops to go
back to 1997.
you know what 1997 was that's when the
soviet union basically fell apart and so
what he was saying is he wants no nato
troops in any of eastern and central
europe and also in the baltics he wants
to pull back on on the lafayette and
estonia
no that wasn't a peace gesture that was
a war gesture well and i i think you're
correct let's not forget that trump was
impeached because he threatened to
withhold federal aid from ukraine you're
correct about that well no no
well we can go into that a separate
issue but we're going to confuse the uh
the conversation i think we should stick
on this and then we can talk about that
he did send federal uh lethal aid to
ukraine and and
again nobody's saying what vladimir
putin is doing is correct right if 44
million people want to be free they have
the right to be free but again i ask
where does this end up why is that our
responsibility
how
what you took objection to is me saying
that uh that ukraine it blunted in the
first month
the russian invasion by using the
citizen militia that's what i said well
that's what i said and what you didn't i
didn't get a chance to but now i'll give
you a chance to become relevant on your
comment to say that what the west should
have been doing from that point
was facilitating what ukraine needed in
order to defend themselves because we
are committed to free freedom and
democracy and you're talking about 44
million people who are dealing i'm not
saying we should have put troops in
there
i am saying we should have allowed the
air equipment to go in there now we are
why are we now allowing it to go in
there because
it
it's it's now apparent that ukraine can
use them and win
but back then we didn't want to get
drawn in why because putin was
threatening us like he's now threatening
us with nuclear weapons putin is a bully
bullies
push until they find a wall yeah putin's
got a problem
he can't win ukraine and he's not going
to be able to win ukraine because of the
ukrainian people if they're given the
tools they need to defend themselves the
polls understand this why are the poles
in the front line here because they know
if ukraine falls to
it becomes part of russia they're the
border
and they know what that means
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]